et ben voilà avec cette blouse rapiécé
et celui chapeau moi je trouve que mon
épouvantail à une bien fière allure et
avec un peu de vent pour le faire bouger
les petits oiseaux penseront que c'est
un être humain bien vivant comme ça
quand on sera pas là bas ils n'auront
pas le toupet de venir chiper des
bonbons monsieur l'épouvantail vous êtes
très élégant vous allez être très
agréable habitants de l'île cher
monsieur l'épouvantail ça alors il ya un
nouvel habitant dans l'île aux enfants
c'est incroyable il est vraiment très
élégant ce monsieur il est encore plus
distingué comme au sud du snob et moi
qui ne me suis pas habillée elle était
moi monsieur l'épouvantail de vous
présenter notre ami casimiro bonjour
monsieur les puces montagne je suis
enchanté mais qu'il ne veut pas me
donner la main
en soit 10 mois il a dit plus
l'épouvantail casimir pas les puces
lanta yahiaoui opus est l'époux les
puces si c'est la même famille
faut pas qu'il a une drôle de tête
il a vraiment une drôle de tête mais dis
moi c'est une nouvelle race ou bien
alors il l'a il a des origines
préhistoriques comme les casini russe à
l'union casimir garde il est fait avec
du bois de la paille et des vieux avis
il ya dix minutes il n'existait pas
encore mais alors une dépend du vent ben
non c'est un mannequin est gelée
tabriquet pour faire peur aux oiseaux ça
alors mais pourquoi voulez vous faire
peur aux oiseaux mais ils voulaient tous
mes bonbons au miel
comment savez vous que c'est que ce sont
les oiseaux qui volaient les bonbons
dansant casimir qui d'autre veux tu que
ce soit bah je ne sais pas moi
en tout cas ce n'est pas moi
nous n'avions pas pensé à casimir c'est
peut-être lui ah bah non non non je ne
crois pas parce que normalement il
n'aime que les dragées au poivre et tu
n'en as pas
françois il est joli vous me décevez
beaucoup ce n'est pas gentil du tout de
faire peur aux oiseaux que vont penser
les enfants nous ne faisons pas mais non
et chez casimir comme ils sont très
malins les petits oiseaux après s'être
envolé de peur une première fois ils
verront bien que l'épouvantail n'est pas
méchant et ils viendront même se percher
dessus bon alors pourquoi avez vous
aurez tout ça ça ne sert à rien la
regarder ça de plus près
aux dégraderont j'adore ça c'est
délicieux du sein avec de la moutarde et
de la confiture de fraises c'est un
joueur n'est pas pour toi
ô vous j'ai compris c'est pour mes amis
les oiseaux exactement casimir et je
vais t'expliquer notre plan avec
l'épouvantail nous faisons peur aux
oiseaux qui n'osent plus s'approcher du
kiosque alors il s'envole un peu plus
loin et là ils découvrent les graines
que leur a préparé julie ainsi qu'en
l'épouvantail ne leur fera plus peur et
misent ont pris l'habitude de manger des
graines y laisseront les bonbons au miel
de julie voilà françois il y a des
moments où tu m'étonnes tu sais que ton
idée n'est pas bête du tout ben merci
pour les autres fois parce que tu penses
que c'est toi quel toujours les
meilleures idées cloyne et alors je
viens d'inventer une nouvelle collection
vraiment
aurait coûté à insister encore un peu et
puis je vous le dirai peut-être nous
assistons tenir à lady nu le vite et
bien voilà j'ai regroupé des objets qui
représentent chacun un des habitants de
l'île à essai destiné je pense aux
visiteurs qui viennent se promener dans
l'îlot z'enfants exactement c'est en
quelque sorte un musée amusé 20-10
françois c'est quoi exactement un musée
mon vieux kazimierz
de mon côté en train de faire un musée
c'est une collection d'objets qui
sortait illustrés chacun l'histoire de
quelqu'un ou de quelque chose c'est vrai
mais je suis formidable j'ai inventé un
musée sans savoir ce que c'était qu'un
musée
à lormes outre revu ses visées bon
d'écouter un boni voir alors
voila mon musée mais mais mais qu'est ce
qui se passe
mais il ne me reste plus que mon vol de
gloubiboulga pourtant je vous assure il
y avait une quantité d'objets très
intéressant c'est un peu maigre pour
faire un musée qu'est ce qu'il y avait
d'autre part il y avait par exemple pour
la can et le chapeau de monsieur du sne
indre la sacoche et la casse tête du
facteur il y avait des plus beaux
ballons il y avait les bonbons au miel
julie il était à l'essai accusés déjà
mis les petits oiseaux
ouais et alors mais coûte casimir mais
c'est du snow des facteurs ont lu
reprendront leurs effets et les enfants
ont pris les balles ou et les bonbons
bas c'est normal c'est pour eux écoutent
les émirs du nac a recommencé sa
collection mais cette fois en demandant
à chacun ne te confier un objet d'accord
d'accord d'accord et bien moi à tout à
l'heure je vais chercher de nouveaux
jouets à l'arrivée du bateau je
t'accompagne julie je t'accompagne dont
casimir ouais bon courage pour ton musée
merci au revoir
au travail bon il faut que je retrouve
tous les objets que j'avais là mais
cette fois il faut que je trouve un
moyen pour qu'on ne les reprenne pas
je crois que j'ai une idée
[Musique]
bien ainsi déguisé en épouvantail
personne n'ose à s'approcher trop près
et de reprendre les objets de mon musée
à j'entends quelqu'un qui vient
quand jérémy c'est insensé cela fait
deux fois que mac est disparue ce qu'un
croyable ne vous plaignez pas trop
monsieur du snob votre canne ne vous ai
guère indispensable pareil
je regrette mon cher et blessant
laquelle je ne suis plus tout à fait le
même jour je me sens oui comme un verre
et en société croyez moi c'est
terriblement gênant mais pour moi moi
c'est bien pire on m'a dérobé ma sacoche
et ma casquette comment voulez vous que
je travaille dans ces conditions on vous
pouvez mettre vos lettres dans votre
poche vous n'avez jamais des kilos à
distribuer ça c'est vrai poursuivis si
c'est la bonne place mais ma casquette
ne vous reste plus qu'à mettre notre
motion sur la tête ils vous protégera du
soleil
oui mais le signe des facteurs qui sont
la casquette à poursuivre portion je
suis je suis désormais aux moines
mais venez voir monsieur du snob ce sont
nos affaires au mais vous avez raison
alors les récupérer mon ami oh mais quel
est cet individu
mais joli nom aux mille manières très
menaçants rebroussons chemin rancinan
cependant qu'il est encore tôt
suivez-moi il nous a peut-être pas
encore plus
mais attention il ya du danger là bas tu
te ranger dans l'îlot trouvé là-bas un
individu que je n'avais pas rencontré la
nuit en coin d'un bois serait qui
pourrait peut-être à le voir ses crédits
de plus près il n'a pas l'air bien
méchant écoutez je riais dans un resto
ne bougeait pas réflexion
mais c'est quasiment
les émirs en épouvantail on aura tout vu
c'est rien c'est casimir qui s'est
déguisé en épouvantail que lui descendre
moi pourquoi nous eh bien je crois qu'il
veut vous faire peur afin que vous ne
reveniez pas les objets qu'ils à
rassembler ses spas il faut vous dire
que casimir a constitué un musée mais
laury d'une le tire enfin ma canne au
musée c'est très flatteur tu veux je je
me donne mon noeud papillon pourquoi
alors le féliciter et le remercier
bonjour monsieur l'épouvantail kkk
nous venons visiter le musée de casimir
l'approché pas propres vous pouvez
regarder mais ne rien toucher ne vous
inquiétez pas on ne touchera rien mais
où est-il casimir nous voudrions le
remercier pour sa bonne idée ah bon
alors attendez je vais aller me chercher
oui
[Musique]
vous avez fait connaissance avec mon ami
les pouvons taire je crois assez le
meilleur gardien que j'ai jamais vu il
faut dire que grâce à lui nous n'avons
touché aucun objet
il a une autorité formidable et je dois
dire que je les trouvais une certaine
élégance ah bon et bien commençons la
visite du musée suivez le guide
voilà tout d'abord vous pouvez voir le
chapeau et la canne du très célèbre
monsieur du sna bas
un peu plus loin
splendide balou un des plus beaux
spécimens de la collection privée de
françois c'est mon préféré c'est l'homme
ensuite la magnifique casquette de
monsieur campagne facteur de lilas et sa
sacoche
ensuite dans le bocal les caramels mous
grande spécialité de julie
en bas du banc les véhicules autorisés
sur l'île aux enfants
et tout au bout
le fameux le célèbre bonne